welcome everyone uh
thanks again to ankuru moitra from mit
who we are lucky to have as a speaker in
our booth camp you'll be telling us
about recent advances
in high dimensional learning uh take it
away ankur
great thanks so much for the
introduction and again for the
invitation to speak so
you know last time what i told you about
was i told you about tensor
decompositions and
i think there'll be a little bit of an
ebb and a flow to these lectures because
last time
i gave you hope you know i told you
about simple algorithms for tensor
decompositions
and i told you about how you can take
lots of probabilistic models and you can
find low rank tensor structure within
them
mostly through trying to find variables
that are conditionally independent
and how you can use uniqueness
properties of the tensor decomposition
as a method to perform parameter
learning
but there's a dirty secret behind those
kinds of methods and that
general viewpoint which is that you know
you don't really believe that your data
actually comes from such a simple
generative model
at best that's close to one of those
generative models
so in this lecture we're gonna ask this
tough question you know what happens
in generative models when our data isn't
exactly from that generative model
and we're going to think about notions
of robustness
so are there algorithms now that can
actually tolerate
some amount of misspecification in your
model
now one of the nice things is that
tensor methods are again going to play a
key role
but let me start where it's always good
to start at the beginning
so let me first start off with one
dimensional problems before we get to
high
dimensional problems and let's not worry
about robustness just yet
so let me tell you about parametric
statistics and this is just a way of
looking at things it's a way of looking
at generative models and thinking about
how do you perform
estimation so imagine that you're given
samples from some
unknown distribution but you know that
it lives in some nice class of
distributions
so one canonical example that we'll use
throughout the stock is the notion
of a gaussian so imagine you know your
samples come from a gaussian but you
don't know the underlying
mean mu and the underlying variance
sigma squared
and the basic question in parametric
statistics is can we
accurately estimate the underlying
parameters from samples
now this is a kind of obvious answer the
answer is da
yes because in fact what you can do is
the obvious thing you can take the
empirical mean and the empirical
variance
so the empirical mean very quickly
converges to the true
unknown mean mu and the empirical
variance so
x bar is is the empirical mean and you
can compute the empirical variance and
that's very quickly going to converge
to the unknown variance sigma squared
in fact these two estimators the
empirical mean and the empirical
variants are two examples of a more
general paradigm within statistics which
is
immensely powerful it's due to fisher
back in the early 1900s
who pioneered the idea of maximum
likelihood estimation so you look for
the parameters
that are the most likely to have
generated the data that you observe
and there are a lot of wonderful
properties about the maximum likelihood
estimator that are known
you need some kind of technical
conditions but under the appropriate
technical conditions
you can prove that not only does the
maximum likelihood estimator converge
the true parameters but it actually does
so at the asymptotically fastest
possible rate
that when you you know fix the estimator
and send the number of samples to
infinity
uh not only does it converge but the
amount by which it's wrong is the best
possible
in a sense now one of the big problems
with the maximum likelihood estimator is
that it's
not necessarily computationally
efficient to actually compute the thing
and that's a major reason why last
lecture we were talking about
tensor methods and the method of moments
because those led to estimators that we
really could compute
so we weren't trying to get the
asymptotically efficient estimator we
were merely trying to get a good
estimator
that was computable in polynomial time
but really i'm going to talk about
another branch of this story which it's
a basic question that was introduced by
john tukey in the 1960s
and there's a question that's so
fundamental that really it could have
been asked
much earlier but it wasn't and tuki's
work
really led to i mean an entire field
called robust statistics
so he asked what about errors in the
model itself
so what happens if your data doesn't
come exactly from a nice distribution it
merely comes from a distribution that's
close
to a nice one so here's the canonical
way that you set up these problems let's
go back to our favorite example imagine
that we have a 1d gaussian and that's
our ideal model
but the trouble is that our observed
model the thing that we're actually
getting samples from
isn't exactly gaussian at best it kind
of resembles a gaussian if you squint at
it
so what we can think about is adding
some type of noise on top of the
distribution
and that leads itself to our observed
model and the question is what can we do
in the face of this noise is there a
sense in which we can still
meaningfully estimate the underlying
parameters
so let me make this question precise
because we need to
really mathematize this question to make
sure that it makes sense when we go to
high dimensions especially
but in order to formalize this question
one of the first questions i have to
answer
is how do we constrain the noise now
there are actually many ways of thinking
about how you could constrain the noise
and these are helpful ways to go back
and forth between
so one way is that you can take that
little twiddle that that i showed you on
the previous slide
which really describes the difference in
the two pdf functions
one pdf being the idealized model and
the other one being the observed model
and you could think about constraining
the l1 norm of this noise
you could constrain the l1 norm it's at
most o of epsilon
let's say another way to think about
this is you can think about it with an
adversary
so if you overlay these two pdfs the
idealized model
and the observed model then you can
think about the region
in between these blue and green curves
and that's the place where the adversary
is either deleting or adding
points so you can also think about this
noise model as
you take samples from some nice
distribution but an adversary gets the
corrupt and o of epsilon
fraction of the samples in expectation
so there's actually some subtleties to
how exactly you define an adversary
so for example there's huber's
contamination model where you think
about an adversary as just
adding a fraction of the samples this
model i'm describing here allows the
adversary to add
and delete samples and actually the
truth is we're going to work with an
even more general model
where the adversary is allowed to look
at the samples drawn from the idealized
model
and then get to decide what samples he
wants to corrupt
now the distinctions between these noise
models won't be very significant in this
talk i just mentioned
it just to let you know and you can
think about it in whichever of these
noise models makes the most sense to you
now let me lastly introduce a little bit
of nomenclature that's going to be
helpful for us up i already see a
question in the q a
are these two models in the slide
equivalent
so um they sort of are but you know
that's why i said
uh arbitrarily corrupt an epsilon
fraction the samples and expectations
actually these two models are equivalent
when the adversary has a budget and
expectation of the fraction of things
that he can corrupt
and this corruption strategy is actually
oblivious to the samples that you
observe
okay so in any case you can think about
it in the simplest model if you want
but let me introduce some helpful
nomenclature that we're going to rely on
throughout this talk
i'll think about the outliers as being
the points that the adversary has
corrupted and the inliers as being the
points
that he hasn't so this is our model for
noise this is what the adversary can do
to move us away from an idealized model
now the remaining thing that i have to
address is
what does it mean to estimate the
parameters
accurately in the face of noise so in
what norm do we want our parameters
to be close now the truth is that in one
dimension there are a lot of norms which
are equally good as each other
you know which one you choose doesn't
really matter but in high dimensions it
really does matter that you choose the
right norm that your problem actually
makes sense
so let me go with the you know the
natural one which is going to generalize
the high dimensions much easier
so there's the notion of the total
variation distance that's just half of
the l1 distance between the two pdfs
and it's defined in this formula and the
important thing to think about
is that what is our observed
distribution well it's any old
distribution that's close in total
variation distance to the idealized
model
so we're given samples from a
distribution that's epsilon close in tv
to an unknown gaussian so we should try
and use the same norm
to define what it means to have good
estimates of the underlying parameters
so what we want is we want to output
another 1d gaussian that's this orange
curve
with the property that its mean and
variance are close enough to what we
started out from
that the orange curve is close to the
blue curve in total variation distance
so the adversary presents you with
samples from a distribution that's
epsilon close to gaussian
in total variation and what you want to
do is you want to find your own gaussian
that's three epsilon close to the
gaussian that you started from
so that's the setup for this problem and
you can also think about it another way
which is that
you know noise isn't always bad it's not
something you're necessarily trying to
remove
a lot of times when you're faced with
data the truth is that the samples
you're given
aren't from a nice model like a gaussian
so you can think about it as
given the promise that there is a 1d
gaussian that really
closely fits your observed distribution
can you find one
that actually is roughly as close as
possible
so these are the different ways to think
about how i frame to the problem this is
how robust statistics traditionally
frames these things and now the next
natural question you might have is
well in the context of maximum
likelihood estimation and estimating the
unknown mean
and variance of an actual gaussian we
knew that the empirical mean and
empirical variance worked
that's what fisher's theory told us so
do these work
in the in the presence of corruptions
and so here the answer is a resounding
no so if you think about it for a few
moments you'll come up with a pretty
easy way to badly derail the empirical
mean and empirical variants
so what would the adversary do they
could add a bump
in the pdf that's way out in the tails
so we end up with this observed model
right over here it looks mostly like a
gaussian but it has a little bump way
out in the tails
and the problem with this now is that
when you take samples from your observed
model well its true mean is arbitrarily
far away as you move the bump further
and
further
away from the true mean you're trying to
estimate
so both the empirical mean and empirical
variance are going to go to infinity
as you send this bump out to infinity
okay so there's a question you don't
care about actually identifying the
corrupted points right
uh that is exactly correct so i'll
discuss this a little bit more because i
want to reveal this in waves but
indeed here we're just talking about
estimating the parameters well
and i don't necessarily care about
identifying which points have been
corrupted
one of the reasons why i'm framing it
this way is because it's not always
possible
to identify which points have been
corrupted the adversary might not do
something obvious like putting a bump
way out in the tails
they might put it in the middle of the
distribution in which case it might be
statistically impossible
to actually tell which points are in
liars and outliers
instead what i want to do is i want to
identify the outliers that are really
far
out there in so much as they derail my
estimator
why three epsilon because it's an
arbitrary constant that i'm not going to
care about
okay so let's um let's move on um so
what uh should work instead of the
empirical mean and empirical variance
so in fact um you know many of you will
immediately be able to guess the answer
that instead of using the empirical mean
what you should use is you should use
the empirical median
because you know when an adversary adds
this bump way out in the tails
well it may pull the mean very far away
from the original mean but it's not
going to pull the median too far out
and in fact if the median works instead
of the mean
what should you do for the variance well
you just use the median twice
so you can work with something called
the median absolute deviation
which what you do is you take the median
of your data and you take the absolute
values of the
of x1 minus the median and you take the
median of those things
and that gives you some rough estimate
for the scale of your distribution
so there's another question which is is
data poisoning included in these noise
models or it's a conceptually very
distinct actually this is literally a
data poisoning model so i'll discuss
some downstream applications in
modern machine learning later but these
are all
different terms for the same thing
adversaries robust statistics data
poisoning models
and in fact i'll introduce even more
nomenclature to connect it to some
classic tcs topics later
all right so in fact you know what's a
folklore theorem in robust statistics in
fact
this theorem is so ingrained into the
dna of robust statistics that
the truth is i don't even know who
proved this theorem first but
it's very clear that many people knew
this so
here's what you can show is good about
the empirical median and the empirical
median absolute deviation is that it's
provably robust
so given samples from any distribution
that's epsilon close and total variation
distance to a 1d
gaussian the median and median absolute
deviation if you run them
and you spit out the parameters mu hat
and sigma hat
then in fact those will be such good
estimates
that the total variation distance
between the unknown gaussian
that happened pre-corruption and the one
that's defined by your mean
and variance estimates will be o of
epsilon
so you started off with something that's
epsilon close to a 1d
gaussian and you ended up with an
actual gaussian that's three epsilon
close to the one that you started from
now just some minor technicalities that
actually to get
sigma hat you need to take the median
absolute deviation
and use the appropriate correctional
constant you need some kind of
correctional constant that depends on
the cdf of a gaussian
just to ensure that if there were no
noise your estimate sigma half would be
an unbiased estimator of the underlying
sigma from the actual distribution
so you know what's amazing about this
theorem just to take a step back
is that it gives you the best of all
possible worlds
so it's provably robust you start off
epsilon close to a gaussian and you
actually do get some provably robust
estimates
it's also computationally efficient
because how do i compute the median and
median absolute deviation
i just compute them and in fact it's
also statistically efficient if i wrote
down the sample complexity would turn
out that it's minimax
optimal it uses the optimal number of
samples up to a constant factor
okay and now let me connect this to you
know the way that
i think about these problems in terms of
terminology so i'm a theoretical
computer scientist and
what this would be called for a
theoretical computer scientist would be
called
proper agnostically learning a 1d
gaussian
so let's break down that terminology a
little bit well it's called
agnostic learning because you're no
longer positing this religious belief
that you really are given samples from a
gaussian distribution
instead you're getting samples from some
distribution and if it happens to be
very well
fit by a gaussian then you want to find
a very good fit
of a gaussian and in fact it's proper
for that reason because we want not just
something that fits the distribution
we're giving samples to
but we actually want it to be back
within our family we want it to
actually be a 1d gaussian i think that
was the other question in the chat
and now i can get to what i really care
about in this talk which is
you know where does what about robust
estimation and high dimension so this is
a tutorial about high dimensional
learning
and in the first part of the tutorial i
talked about how to use tensor methods
to get
algorithms for high dimensional learning
but let's talk about what happens when
we deviate from those nice generative
models
you know is there a way to still do
estimation
in high dimensions in a computationally
efficient manner
but in a way that we still have
interesting guarantees
when we have model misspecification
and in fact um you know one of the
things you should think about is that
there's all kinds of data analysis and
high dimensions going on
right now all over the place you can
think about some examples from genetics
like doing microarrays with
10 000 genes the problem with doing high
dimensional data analysis in these
settings is that
we really do have noisy data but we
don't know how to visualize these kinds
of high dimensional data sets
so we don't even have a good
understanding of how much the noise
that's in these data sets
is biasing the off-the-shelf estimators
that we're using
and i think this is a major issue for
science and engineering these are just
questions
we don't generally know how to answer
it's kind of a dirty secret
all right so now um let me tell you some
of the bad news let me tell you about
the tension
between robustness and hardness
in high dimensions this is something
that we just didn't see happening in
one-dimensional robust estimation
problems
but is really something we have to
tackle head on in high dimensional
settings
so let me define the world's simplest
robust high dimensional estimation
problem
so imagine we have the same exact
problem except we have a d-dimensional
gaussian
so we're given samples from a
distribution that's not exactly a
gaussian but
it's promised to be epsilon close in tv
to a d-dimensional gaussian now the
difference is that here the unknown mean
mu is a d-dimensional vector and the
unknown covariance
sigma is a d-by-d psd matrix
right but the goal is the same what we
want to do
is we want an efficient algorithm that
also takes only a polynomial number of
samples
and it's going to spit out an estimate
mu hat and sigma hat so high dimensional
estimates of the mean
and covariance with the property that
the gaussian that they define
is o tilde epsilon close to the original
gaussian that we started from so now let
me make good on one of the promises that
you know i made before which is you know
in 1d it really
didn't matter a whole heck of a lot on
how you define
what it means for the parameters that
you estimate and the true parameters to
be close
but actually in high dimensions it
matters a whole heck of a lot
that's because if you think about how
close do i want sigma and sigma hat to
be
those are d by d matrices so you know do
i want them to be close
in terms of you know i look at the
spectral norm of sigma minus sigma hat
do i want the forbiddenious norm between
sigma and sigma
sigma minus sigma hat to be small do i
want some other norm
all of these different matrix norms they
often differ by poly and d
factors so you need to make sure that
you choose the right norm
that's why it makes sense to work with
total variation distance because that
characterizes what the adversary has
done to your distribution
they move you in total variation
distance and you want to get
within total variation distance again
so this is the way that the pro this is
the reason the problem is set up the way
that it is
and now let me introduce just a little
bit more nomenclature because i'm going
to dig into some of these problems and
tell you what's known
so i could make your life easier in this
problem and
you know work with one of the following
two special cases
so one special case is i could make your
life easier
and i could promise you that the unknown
covariance sigma is actually the
identity
so it's a spherical gaussian and you
just want to estimate the center
of that gaussian so can you robustly
estimate the mean of a high dimensional
spherical gaussian
i'll call that the unknown mean case
instead what i could do is i could make
your life simpler by promising you
that the unknown mean is zero and all
you have to do is estimate the unknown
covariance
so what the shape of this ellipsoid is
for this ellipsoidal gaussian
so what's known in the case of the
unknown mean so if you think about it
in the one-dimensional problem we knew
that the median
was a good provably robust estimator for
the unknown mean
so the natural thing to try is to try
and use a high dimensional analog
of the median well that's exactly what
tuki did
so there's something called the tukey
media now i'll preface this by saying
that
you don't actually have to know what the
tukey median is to understand the rest
of the talk but let me just tell you in
words what the tukey median is
well you can think about this point
cloud of samples that you get from your
distribution
and there's something called the tukey
depth of a point which is if i take a
point i look at the worst case
over all 1d projections about how close
it is to the end point
of the projections of all of these
points so the tukey median
is the tuki deepest point so it's the
point that sits in the middle of the
distribution
that no matter what 1d projection you
choose it's somehow sitting in the
middle of all of the other projections
now the tukey median would be great
because in fact
you know what's known about it is that
if you
start with something that's epsilon
close to a spherical gaussian
then the 2k median will be such a good
estimate a robust estimate of the
unknown mean of the distribution
that it'll actually get you epsilon
close and total variation distance
but there's a big catch which is that
you can't actually compute the thing
so it's np-hard in fact what this means
concretely is that if you have
n samples from a d-dimensional point set
and you want to compute the tukey median
the best-known algorithms run in time
roughly end of the d
so even though the tukey median is very
well studied in computational geometry
in low dimensional settings
i have never seen it be successfully
computed beyond
dimension 6. so these kinds of high
dimensional applications that we care
about in
a lot of modern machine learning are
just way out of the reach of these kinds
of estimators because you can't actually
compute them
even though we do know that if we could
they would be provably robust
now there's something much more naive i
could do maybe i just chose the wrong
generalization of the median to high
dimensions
so there's something really naive i
could do which is i could just choose
the coordinate wise median
of the distribution so i look at each of
the coordinate
uh the distribution projected on each of
the coordinates and i compute the median
and i stitch them together to get my
high dimensional estimate
that's very obviously computable in
polynomial time because it's just
d different median problems the trouble
is that
it really loses in the error guarantee
so you start off being epsilon close to
a gaussian and you only end up
epsilon times root d close back to the
original gaussian
this is not an issue that you see when d
equals one
but this is a major issue when you talk
about robust estimation
in high dimensions and i'll talk a
little bit more about that in the next
slide about what is just so bad about
losing this root d
factor but you can do this exercise for
all of the estimators that have been
proposed in the literature
everything that has a great dimension
independent error guarantee
turns out to come with this hidden
gotcha that you can't actually compute
the thing
so you know in my field in theoretical
computer science we love the phrase
the price of so maybe this is just kind
of the price of robustness
because all these known estimators
they're either hard to compute
in high dimensions or we lose some
polynomial in d
factors in our robustness guarantee
so what is so bad about this is that the
total variation distance between
two distributions is only ever at most
one
so the way to think about it is how
small do i need the fraction of
corruptions to be
in order to have any non-trivial
guarantees on how good my estimator is
i need the fraction of corruptions to be
like one over root d
so the fraction of corruptions needs to
be plummeting to zero
as you go to higher and higher
dimensions in order for these estimators
to give you
anything non-trivial even if you're
thinking about a problem in 10 000
dimensions with no hidden consonants in
your robustness guarantee
this means that you can only tolerate
something like one percent corruptions
even though we know in principle that
it's possible to tolerate a much larger
fraction of corruptions that's totally
dimension independent
so at this juncture you might actually
wonder is robust
estimation even algorithmically possible
so there's another question in the chat
which is can you switch from tv to kl
so that's a little bit of a technical
answer if you don't mind i'm going to
answer that at the end so maybe
remind me because i don't want to get
too sidetracked right now but thanks for
the question
so let me tell you about some recent
results i'm actually going to tell you
about the first wave of results and at
the end of the talk i'll tell you about
really a flurry of progress in this area
and i'll give you a broad survey
of it so a couple of years ago
me and some great people we proved the
following result
there's an algorithm that takes a
polynomial number of samples
which has the property that if you're
given samples from a distribution that's
epsilon close
in tv to a d dimensional gaussian it
finds
robust estimates of the high dimensional
mean and covariance
that gets you o tilde of epsilon close
so there are no d factors whatsoever not
even log d
terms here and you can get truly
dimension independent robustness
guarantees
and the algorithm runs in time
polynomial in n
and d so you can be both provably robust
sample efficient and computationally
efficient
in these settings so there really is
something that you can do
even when you deviate from these very
simple generative models
and in fact tensor methods are going to
play a key role not generic's algorithm
but
really the tensor structure of the
generative model will still
you know be a very useful primitive in
figuring out
how to cope with corruptions in your
data so there are a few extensions of
this work and i'll talk about many more
extensions later
but you can actually weaken the
assumptions you don't need the
distribution to
actually be gaussian it you need merely
that the inliers are sub gaussian or
bounded second moments
albeit you get weaker robustness
guarantees for things like mean
estimation
at the same time independently and
concurrently lai rao and venpala gave
the following algorithm for robustly
estimating a d-dimensional gaussian
so they managed to get mu hat as
the l2 norm between mu and mu hat
is roughly epsilon to the one half times
some extra factors that depend on the
underlying covariance
times a poly log and d factor and they
also got balance on how close
sigma and sigma hat are in forbinius
norm
now you can translate these results to
bounds on the total variation distance
under some additional conditions on your
distribution
it turns out that when the underlying
distribution
has a bounded covariance what this
really translates to is that your
estimates are close enough that you're
epsilon to the one-half close in tv to
the gaussian that you started off from
okay so let me tell you now a general
recipe
about robust estimation in high
dimensions
in fact these estimators are you know
pretty easy and built on some general
concepts that have since
been applied to all sorts of richer
models so here's how robust estimation
and high dimensions is going to work
algorithmically the first step will be
that you know i want my estimates to be
close
in total variation distance and what i'm
going to do
is total variation distance is a really
ugly thing to work with
instead what i'm going to do is i'm
going to find an appropriate parameter
distance that's easier that's sufficient
to bound it so that i can get strong
guarantees on tv
then step two is we're going to do
something a bit more naive
instead of trying to design one
estimator that works no matter what
corruptions the adversary adds
what we're going to do is we're going to
be adaptive we're just going to use the
naive estimator the empirical mean the
vertical covariance
but we're going to figure out some
clever ways of detecting
when the adversary has compromised that
estimator
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to be able to find many outliers
and purify our data by removing them so
that's basically how high dimensional
estimation is going to work
so actually let's see how this works in
the simplest setting
which is the case where we just want to
estimate the unknown mean and the
covariance is
the identity so first
what's the right parameter distance for
bounding the total variation distance
between two spherical gaussians
now for those of you who think a lot
about different distance measures
between distributions and this ties into
clemont's question earlier about what
can i do with the kl
then it turns out that a good way to
bound the total variation distance
is to use the kl divergence because the
nice thing is that the kale divergence
between two gaussians has a closed form
expression
and through pinsker's inequality you can
say that bounds on the kl divergence
imply balance on the total variation
distance now if you do this what it
tells you is it tells you this very nice
intuitive fact that if you have two
gaussians with the same
identity covariance but they only differ
in the mean mu
and mu hat then the total variation
distance between them is
upper bounded by the euclidean norm
between mu and mu hat
divided by 2. now this makes sense
because
really when you have these two gaussians
that only differ in the mean
figuring out what their total variation
distance is is really a 1d problem
because you should just take the line
that connects mu
and mu hat and that's where all of the
differences between
the two pdfs arise so i'm going to take
this fact for granted but this is how
you prove it as you
invoke pinsker's inequality and you use
the well-known formula for the kl
divergence between two gaussians
but this means that we have a new way to
formulate our problem
our goal in the case where we want to
robustly estimate the unknown mean
is that we want to output a mu hat
that's o
tilde of epsilon close in the euclidean
norm
to the true unknown mean
so this is our goal so now let me get to
the meat of
you know how exactly these things are
going to work so
you know how can we detect when an
estimator a naive one like the empirical
mean has been compromised
so let's think about this problem
geometrically so when we have a high
dimensional gaussian with identity
covariance
then what happens is that your
distribution looks like a high
dimensional
spherical ball all of the distribution
is really concentrated on a thin
spherical shell of a ball of radius root
d
and the center of that ball is at mu so
now how could the adversary
really corrupt the empirical mean well
what they would do
is they would add a bunch of corruptions
right on the boundary of this ball
but they would concentrate them along
some direction
so that they have an epsilon fraction of
corruptions and the points
at the boundary this ball are root d
away from the center of the ball which
is mu
so this epsilon fraction of corruptions
can move you epsilon times root d away
from the true mean that you'd started
out at
so this unravels a bit about why the
question is formulated the way that you
are
see if i hide for you the colors of
these different samples if i don't tell
you which one is black and which one is
red
you have no chance of figuring out which
of the samples were in liars and which
ones were outliers
because these red points will look
statistically indistinguishable from the
true
samples if i do it right and so instead
my goal
isn't to detect which points have been
corrupted and which ones haven't
it's merely to detect when the naive
estimator has been compromised
in such a situation like this i can hope
to figure out
well a subset of the points which is
much more red than black which if i
throw it out
i'm going to end up with an easier
robust estimation problem
so you know how can i detect that my
naive estimator has been compromised
well if i think about projecting all of
my data along the direction that
connects mu and mu hat
then this direction would actually have
variance that's much much larger than
one
so i started from an uncorrupted
distribution which is supposed to have
variance one in all possible directions
but instead by virtue of what the
adversary has done to compromise the
empirical mean
i have a direction of very large
variance
so here's the key llama which i'm not
going to prove for you if you take
samples from a distribution that's
epsilon close to a gaussian
n of mu i and you take enough samples
then if you compute the empirical mean
mu hat of your
samples which come from you know along
with corruptions
and you compute the empirical covariance
sigma hat
then what i claim is if your estimator
mu hat is not good
if it's too far away from the true mean
if the euclidean norm
the euclidean distance between mu and mu
hat is at least 100 times
epsilon root log 1 over epsilon then
what that means is that there has to be
a direction of large variance
that the spectral norm of the difference
between sigma hat
and i is at least epsilon times log one
over epsilon
and so what's the main takeaway from
this lemma so what's the abstraction
is that in order for an adversary to
corrupt
the empirical first moment there
actually needs to be some echo
of what they've done in the second
moment
and that's how you figure out where the
adversary has added the corruptions
and now how can we put this all together
to get our overall
algorithm is we're just going to do a
win-win algorithm and the basic idea is
you know we're just going to use the
empirical mean
and either that will be a good enough
estimate on its own
or we're going to find some way to
remove
many outliers many of the corruptions
that the adversary is added to our data
to get an easier robust estimation
problem
so you know if we compute the empirical
mean and the covariance is really
close to the identity then the converse
of that key lemma i gave you implies
that the estimate mu hatch you have is
actually close to the unknown mean mu so
what happens if sigma hat is not close
to the identity and we know we're
potentially in danger
so what happens if the spectral norm
between sigma had
and identity is large so in this case
the reason that the empirical variance
is large along some direction
must be due to the outlier so if we take
the
direction of largest variance in sigma
hat
and we project the data along that
direction what we show
is that there's some sort of threshold t
so that if you throw out all the points
above this threshold
then you throw out many more outliers
than inliers because those are the ones
that you have large variants along this
direction
now some inliers do get thrown out along
the way but for every inlayer you throw
out
you throw at least let's say two
outliers along the way
so eventually even though in this first
step you didn't get a provably robust
estimate for the unknown mean
you're making progress because your data
has gotten more pure
because you've reduced the fraction of
corruptions within it
and in fact what's going to happen is
eventually if we continued
for too long we'd actually have no more
corrupted points left to throw out
so this eventually finds certifiably
good parameters
this is one of the reasons why we have
to work with the strong contamination
model where the adversary is allowed to
look at the data
and then decide what corruptions to add
because
you know in step one even if you start
from a nice model where the adversary is
choosing the corruptions obliviously
after the first filtering step you don't
really have control over what your data
looks like
even the inliers are not iid necessarily
from a nice distribution
because of the correlations that are
introduced in this filtering procedure
it turns out to be not super easy to
prove that this algorithm really does
work
but it can be done through the
appropriate things that you can actually
get a polynomial
running time bound and polynomial sample
complexity
and yeah i'm sorry you guys are asking
such good questions in the chat that you
know i'm always cognizant of the fact
that if i actually answer them during it
i might break some of the flow
for it because these are kind of
technical answers so i'm going to try
and answer both
clemont's later question and anna's
question towards the end if that's okay
thanks for the questions though and
actually the sample complexity bounds
are based on what's called
concentration of ltfs all right
so now let's um let's take this uh
general recipe much further
so the unknown mean case is actually not
super hard to do you could have
done it many different ways the unknown
covariance case is now what we're going
to get into tensor methods again
so in fact what we're going to do is
we're going to follow the same general
recipe
so here's remember our robust our
estimate our
our recipe for robust estimation high
dimensions is first we've got to find
the appropriate parameter distance
let's figure out how to do this in the
case where we just have an unknown
covariance
so actually we do the same trick as
before you know we want some parameter
distance that's
good enough to bound the total variation
distance between two gaussians
which have the same zero mean and you do
the same trick you know pinsker's
inequality works the kale divergence
between
two gaussian still has a nice closed
form expression
but what it gives you is this kind of
funky expression right here
which relates sigma and sigma hat and
this is actually called the mahalanobis
distance
our new goal is to find an estimate
where the mahalanobis distance is small
and actually if you look at it it kind
of makes sense because you know when the
mean is zero
and you think about sigma and sigma hat
what this thing looks like is it looks
like the ratio of the variances along
different directions
and if you ever have a direction in
which the ratio of the variances is very
far off from each other
you can't be close in total variation
distance so when i asked at the
beginning you know what's the right
distance function to use between how
close sigma and sigma hat ought to be
well the answer was none of them it's
not to use the spectral norm it's not to
use the frobenius norm
the right thing to do is actually use
this mahalanobis distance that's
actually the thing that's affine
invariant if you look at it
appropriately and it actually is the
right one in order to bound the total
variation distance
so now let me just give you a flavor of
how to do this for the unknown
covariance and we'll see
tensor methods again come to the rescue
so what happens if we're given samples
from a gaussian n of zero
sigma and i want to do the same thing i
tried to do before
you know i want to use the naive
estimator the empirical covariance sigma
hat
now this isn't going to work all the
time but at the very least i want a
method to determine
when this naive estimator has been
corrupted
so here's the key fact so imagine you
take samples from
a gout sigma and you know if we're
trying to detect whether the empirical
second moment has been compromised the
natural thing to do is to use the fourth
moment as a test
now the fourth moment would be a tensor
but you know tensors in some cases are
actually hard to work with the problem
here we're talking about is not a tensor
decomposition problem it's something
else
so instead what we're going to do is
we're going to flatten the tensor
to create a much larger matrix so the
fourth moment of this distribution would
naturally look like a d
by d by d by d tensor instead we're
going to flatten it into a d squared by
d
squared matrix m which is the
expectation of x sub i
tensor x sub i all times itself
transpose
so the key point is that this matrix m
is actually very nice
now you have to be careful because it's
only nice when you restrict to the right
space
but if you're restricted to operating on
the right vector space
then actually it has this beautiful
structure which is
it looks like two times sigma tensor two
times sigma flat times sigma flat
transpose
now i've just kind of invented what this
flat symbol is what it is is it's a
rearrangement of the matrix so you take
a d
by d matrix and you rearrange it into a
length d squared
vector and you take it times its own
transpose
now i'm not going to prove this fact for
you it's proved using something called
israelis theorem or wicks formula which
what it does is it relates the moments
of a gaussian to
matchings and it turns out that there's
a relationship between the fourth
moment of a gaussian and matchings in
the complete graph on four notes
now what happens is that m really has
three different kinds of terms that
correspond to the three perfect
matchings in a complete graph on four
nodes
two of the matchings look like the sigma
tensor2
and one of them looks like sigma flat
times sigma flat transpose
that comes from this asymmetry that when
we flatten the thing
and we think about pairing up the
different copies of x sub i
well if i pair up this x of i and the
outer one and these two right here
one of the pairings corresponds the row
and one corresponds the column
and similarly if i pair up this guy with
this guy and this guy with this guy
one corresponds the row and column but
this pairing is a little bit different
because it pairs
elements of the row space and this guy
pairs elements the column space
so that's the sense in which one of the
matchings behaves differently
and this is actually a major problem
because if i think about an adversary
who's adding corruptions to sigma hat
that really derails my estimator
somehow i want to look at spectral
properties of m as a way to determine
where the corruptions have been added
but the trouble is imagine you look at
this formula and you plug in sigma is
the identity matrix
well if i take the identity tensor the
identity that's still the identity its
spectral norm is one
nothing's happening there but if i take
i flat
times i flat transpose that's a rank 1
matrix and actually its spectral norm is
polynomially large in d
so there's a huge shadow for the
adversary to add corruptions
within and that's where the adversary
could hide
unless you know how to project out this
one term
in exactly the right way so it turns out
that there is a way to project out this
one term in exactly the right way
actually since i'm sort of short on time
i'm actually just going to assert it but
it turns out there's a way to set it up
through restricted eigenvalue
computations
that what you can show is that in order
for the adversary to mess up
the second moment but then they really
do
there has to be some echo of what
they've done in the fourth moment that
you can detect through this restricted
eigenvalue computation
on this flattening of the fourth moment
of the distribution
so you can turn this into an algorithm
for the overall problem because what you
can do
is you can first use a doubling trick
where you take twice the number of
samples and if you look at the
differences between them
those samples will look like they come
from something close
to a gaussian they look like something
that comes they look like
samples from a distribution that's o of
epsilon close
to a gaussian whose mean is zero because
the mean cancels out and you've doubled
the covariance
you can use the algorithm for the
unknown covariance to learn sigma hat
then you can apply sigma hat inverse to
your data that's like a kind of agnostic
isotropic position
and then you can robustly learn the mean
in this setting
and this turns out to be the right
distance in which to estimate the mean
because if there's a direction of very
small variance
that's a direction in which you'd really
better get the unknown mean correct
and this gives you the overall algorithm
for agnostically learning a high
dimensional gaussian
with dimension independent robustness
guarantees
so you know after our work there was
actually a huge flurry of progress so
much that it's actually honestly hard
for me to keep up with so let me in the
last few minutes
tell you a bird's-eye view of some of
the exciting things
with the caveat that this isn't even all
of the stuff that's happened it's been
kind of amazing how much stuff has
happened
so one of the questions you might wonder
first is um you know we gave
algorithms which got o of epsilon times
poly log
one of repsolon guarantees and you could
ask
you know is it possible to get o of
epsilon so that turns out to be
computationally hard at least in the
sense that we can prove lower bounds for
a natural family of algorithms called
statistical query learning algorithms
that's only true in the strong
corruption model where the adversary can
do insertions and deletions
that these things in order to beat
epsilon root log one over epsilon must
make a super polynomial number of
queries
actually the intuition for this is
really simple
you know if you think about where
epsilon times log one of epsilon comes
from
as you know how could an adversary move
you not just the mean by
epsilon but epsilon times log one of
epsilon
is if you take a 1d gaussian the
adversary could cut out one of the tails
and when they cut out the tail that
would move you by epsilon times
log 1 over epsilon even in 1d so in
order to avoid
losing that root log term you would have
to notice that you're actually
missing a tail and fill in the tail so
somehow
algorithms that beat this epsilon times
root log one of reps on they would have
to be very brittle
in a different sense that they would
have to very strongly rely on the
structure of the uncorrupted
distribution and exactly what the tales
look like
in order to figure out that's what the
adversary had done
you can also ask different kinds of
questions that tie in with other areas
of
theoretical computer science you could
ask you know what happens when an
adversary corrupts
not you know at most 10 percent of the
data but
90 percent of the data you know so what
happens if the adversary can corrupt the
majority
of the samples the first time you think
about this question it seems like
you can't really say too much that's
interesting because
you know an adversary might if they
could corrupt 90
of the data well you might get samples
from a gaussian and then they might add
a bunch
more gaussian components that are just
as heavy as the gaussian you started off
from
and you would have no way of actually
figuring out which was the true
original gaussian so in this case what
character steinhardt and valiant showed
is that you can solve the problem in a
list decoding sense
so you can output a small list of
hypotheses with the promise
that at least one element of the list
really is provably close
to the estimate through the unknown mean
that you started off from
and there have been various improvements
on these algorithms that
get better improved guarantees although
under stronger conditions so you need
not just that the covariance is bounded
but under some kind of
gaussianity or other higher bounded
moments assumptions
there are also notions of you know
relaxing distributional assumptions some
of this we did in our original paper
but a really beautiful line of work was
really completed in this kothari sawyer
and hopkins lee papers
where they showed tight balance for you
know what level of bounded moments you
want to assume
if you assume that you have bounded
kaith moments in fact you need a
slightly stronger condition
that not only are the kf moments
sub-gaussian
but you need that there's actually a low
degree proof
in the language of sum of squares you
know for the subgaussianity
then you can actually get these kind of
error guarantees as you have more and
more
moment information the estimator
improves in the sense that it approaches
this optimal epsilon dependence but in
fact when all you know
is that you have bounded moments this
epsilon to the one minus one over k
type of dependence is actually the best
that you can hope for
information theoretically so this is a
really neat line of work too
another paper that i really like in the
space is a different take on robust
estimation
which is what happens when there aren't
corruptions but instead you have
heavy tail distributions so in that case
you know if you didn't have heavy tail
distributions you could just use the
empirical mean like if you get samples
from a gaussian
and you would get very very narrow
confidence intervals
but when you have heavy tail
distributions it turns out to be much
more subtle in order to how to get
very tight confidence intervals so a
really nice work of sam hopkins showed
how to do this
actually using sum of squares to get
nice gaussian type confidence intervals
the important thing is that what it
outputs is an estimate mu hat
that this confidence interval the width
depends logarithmically on whatever
delta where
delta is your failure probability and
there were earlier approaches
like the approach of lugosian mendelson
that showed how to get these types of
confidence intervals but
inefficiently based on something called
the median of means estimator
some of the ideas that i described play
some kind of conceptual role
in for example hopkins's work and even
some of the later improvements which
gave faster algorithms based on
gradient descent so let me stop there so
let me tell you what i hope
that you got out of the talk so really
we started from this question about what
happens when we don't have a nice
generative model
it turns out that even if you take the
world's simplest generative model
a high dimensional gaussian which no one
would ever ask can you learn a high
dimensional gaussian the answer is duh
of course you can you get very
interesting questions when you ask can
you learn it
robustly and actually there are
approaches based on ideas from tensor
analysis and restricted eigenvalue
problems so
you know some of the same actors that we
saw last time that can give you provably
robust estimators
that robustness with computational
efficiency in interesting ways
i give you some other applications to
other kinds of generative models and
and related problems and i think there's
um
you know there's a lot more to be doing
in the space in algorithmic robust
statistics
just to give you a little bit of a
preview about what i'm going to talk
about next time you can think about all
the problems that i described today as
really being
unsupervised learning problems what i'm
going to discuss
tomorrow will be robustness in the
context of supervised learning
where again there's going to be this
funny business that you know there are a
few ways to define
what your corruption models are in the
context of supervised learning there are
going to be some interesting quirks
about
which kinds of corruption models are
just too computationally hard to work
with
and which other ones really are the
right compromise
between both having strong corruption
models and
leading to actual algorithmic guarantees
so i'll stop there thanks for your
attention and
um i'll answer any questions you guys
might have i see a few questions on the
chat so i can start there
um yeah and uh thanks ankur and also if
you if you have a question you can
feel free to raise your hand and um we
can meet you to ask you
live
okay so clements uh first question that
i haven't answered
is does the error guarantee tend to o of
epsilon if you let
n go to infinity or even more
so um no so actually they really do
get epsilon times poly log one over
epsilon
so in the strong contamination model we
had a later follow-up paper that
actually improved the guarantees and
robust mean estimation
and got epsilon times log 1 of epsilon
which is the thing that matches this sql
lower bound
one of the funny things is that you can
go back to the huber contamination model
where remember you're not allowed as an
adversary to delete points from your
sample you're only allowed to
inject new points and in those kinds of
injection models you actually can get o
of epsilon for the robust mean
estimation
because you can't do this trick of like
deleting a tail
so that's kind of cool that you know
there are actual genuine differences not
only between
which robustness models are stronger
than others
but even what you could hope to achieve
you know in terms of computational
complexity
so that i think is kind of neat and
there is some genuine barrier for some
of these models
then anna asked is there a sense in
which some adversaries are complete for
a class of adversaries or is it possible
to do reductions between
adversaries or tasks to perform on the
corrupted data you know i'm not sure i
have a really
meaningful answer to that one
because um you know even very close by
adversaries that seem to be pretty
closely related i don't know how to
literally relate the two
so you know when i talked about one view
of the corruption model as the adversary
gives you samples from any distribution
that's epsilon close in tv to the
distribution you started with
that looked like an adversary who one
had to choose obliviously which data
points to corrupt without looking at the
rest of the sample so they have to
choose their strategy
and the way that their strategy is
constrained is that in expectation it
has to add not too many corruptions
um you know even slight variance of
these kinds of things where
you know the where you're allowed to not
be oblivious and actually look at parts
of the data
i don't know how to relate those back to
the original model
so it's kind of interesting but to be
honest i don't have any religious
reasons for why
one corruption model is the right one
compared to the others
it's honestly more that the reason we
worked with the strong contamination
model
was a strong corruption model was
because in our analysis
we had to so after the first step of the
filtering approach
well you know in principle the adversary
could have added corruptions in a way
that
the in liars that you throw out had some
weird statistical relationships amongst
each other
and then in the second step of your
filtering algorithm
you know the remaining inliers might
have some weird dependent structure
on each other so then you know the
adversary
is somehow like the corruptions that are
left over don't look like any kind of
nice model with the data that's left
over
so just by virtue of the analysis of the
algorithm it seemed
necessary to to work with these stronger
uh corruption models but that's a very
good question
um next question is for gaussian mean
estimation
with unknown covariance can we learn the
mean with optimal rate in linear and d
number of samples that is without first
robustly estimating the covariance
okay so first you know optimal
rate so i mean there are a few
interrelated questions here
so i guess you know because the unknown
mean case you can't hope to get o of
epsilon at least under computational
considerations i'm interpreting your
question as
you know can you get roughly close to
epsilon f o tilde of epsilon
do the trick but in the case where you
don't know the covariance i don't
actually know the answer to this
question
because what's funny is that in order to
learn the covariance well enough
you know within let's say forbinius norm
you need d
squared samples so that's already a d
factor larger than
you need to learn the mean in the known
covariance case
so i think that's a very interesting
open question and i i don't know it's a
it's a nice question
oh boy there are a lot of questions all
right so next one
from clement again
is uh does anything change at all if you
ask that the adversary be
efficient as well
that's an awesome question you know this
is sort of more thinking like a
cryptographer
that um a lot of times that's how you
make a huge amount of progress in crypto
is that your adversary isn't an
arbitrary information theoretic
adversary but is
one that is computationally bounded
i've never actually been able to make
much sense of that in the context of
learning
just to connect this with some of the
things that i talked about last time
you know there are many different
adversaries you could imagine here we
had ones that are computationally
unbounded
and you know the things that i talked
about even for like learning mixtures of
gaussians last time with
tensor methods you know why do you
expect the mean vectors to be linearly
independent is because
if you perturb them then they would be
so i like thinking about smooth analysis
as a good way to limit your adversary as
i like to think about it
i guess this is still recorded but i'll
say it anyways i like to think about it
as an adversary who's a little bit drunk
because you know he moves and his hand
tremors and that for me has been a very
powerful way to
to curb the power of the adversary is
to um you know make him drunk like
smooth analysis
but i've never seen ways to do it based
on uh constraining the adversary's
computational complexity
except in some somewhat more um you know
specialized models but
i would be happy to learn of counter
examples
okay so the next question is so
how about the improper case where your
goal is to just come up with some
distribution that's close in tv
to the original presumably that's easier
because the corrupted distribution
is already close to the ideal um
so i don't actually know any examples in
which that's easier in a high
dimensional setting
so improper learning tends to be much
much stronger in low dimensional
settings even for classic learning
problems
like if i want to in 1d learn a mixture
of k gaussians
we don't actually know how to do this in
better than
exponential and k time with proper
density estimation so where i want to
output something that really is a
mixture of k gaussians
that's close in tv to the underlying
distribution
but there's a really trivial way to do
it with improper learning
which is what you can do is you take a
bunch of samples from distribution and
convolve it by a small gaussian that
smooths the density function
and that'll work so there are already
some examples of where this can be
really beneficial in low dimensions i've
never seen it successful in high
dimensions
for some of the basic estimation tasks
and they're actually lower bounds for a
lot of those problems
and one of the issues is that imagine in
the context of robustness hypothetically
that you could improperly learn
something that's close to the original
distribution
well that's still only close to the
original distribution it's like two
epsilon close the original distribution
so the task then of finding you know
something that really
is uh from your family that's now close
to that thing that you've learned
i don't know how to solve that problem
because it sounds like almost the same
robust estimation task as i started with
if only for the fact that because i have
a description of the hypothesis i don't
actually need to take more samples
so that kind of thing would be really
beneficial to make sure that you don't
take too many samples
but still this computational question of
searching within the space
where you merely have very good 10
agreement rather than arbitrarily small
agreement
seems kind of tricky to me
now bryce asks you present examples of a
heuristic
try the naive statistic detect when the
knife statistic has been corrupted then
fix the naive heuristic and the
detection step looks at deviations of
the naive statistic
is there a formalization of this
heuristic or is it done
ad hoc each time
this is done sometimes a little bit ad
hoc
because you know there's some bias in
the examples that i presented for you
which is that these are all examples in
which there is a nice parameter distance
that bounds the total variation distance
now when you talk about learning more
sophisticated generative models
like mixtures of general gaussians there
isn't
actually a nice perimeter distance that
in all
cases is sufficient to bound the total
variation distance
with dimension independent guarantees
some of the learning algorithms based on
tensor methods based on
the method of moments things that i'd
worked on earlier
those give you parameter distances that
have
are polynomially related to the tv
between two hypotheses
but with dimension dependent factors
so that's actually one of the things
that goes wrong and there's been a lot
of progress that i didn't even have time
to talk
about in this talk on robustly learning
mixtures of gaussians
which design some kind of you know i
mean very clever but
you know things that are a little bit ad
hoc in the sense that they work for
various special cases of mixture models
that have nicer ways of controlling
you know when different hypothesis
classes are close to each other
so they can sort of carve out some space
of the set of hypotheses you want to
learn
and figure out that these are settings
in which you do have a nice perimeter
distance
in fact daniel kane has a pretty amazing
work that uh you know solves the thing
for mixtures of two gaussians
that invents some you know parameter
distance that uh
only daniel kane could dream up but
anyways i encourage you to check it out
it's pretty neat
i think that's all the questions yeah it
looks like all the questions uh there
was a question that i
thought that you would address that you
maybe just now
sort of addressed that i had dismissed a
little bit earlier let me see if i can
dig it up just because i want to give it
a dude diligence
uh sorry i think this was
question are there robust estimator
results for gaussian mixtures
right yeah that's the one oh sorry could
you say it again
are there robust estimate
yeah so um there are now
somewhat in the sense that um there's a
you know two works at fox i think they
were merged which were very nice which
study the question in the special case
where
the mixture of k gaussians has the
property
that all of the components are pairwise
far
in total variation distance so then you
can get
nice provably robust dimension
independent guarantees
now one of the things that i do want to
point out is that these things
tend to if i remember correctly not get
o of epsilon or o tilde of epsilon
closeness but they get
uh epsilon to the omega one so think
like epsilon to the one sixth or
something like this
so even though there are very strong
guarantees in that setting
and you know that is a setting in which
you really that's the setting in which
you most often want to learn a mixture
of k gaussians is when the components
are actually pretty distinct
in those kinds of settings you can get
properly robust things but there's still
nice questions about improving the
dependence on
epsilon in fact i see a question
in here who might be one of the authors
in the paper from aynesh
um yeah
in the case where the mixtures are
clusterable you can get you can
characterize tv distance in terms of
parameter distance exactly
so that sort of fits in with one of the
other questions that i was addressing
that
in that special case of mixtures of k
gaussians which admittedly is one of the
most
interesting cases that's something where
there is a nice parameter distance that
actually relates to tv
but you know for mixture and so daniel
kane has a recent work
which you know gets the same epsilon to
the c types of guarantees for mixtures
of two gaussians
with almost no assumptions the only
assumption he needs
is that the mixing weights are the same
which is kind of a bizarre
assumption probably someone could remove
that
or you could try and improve the epsilon
of the c type of dependence
but no one knows the full answer for
mixtures of k gaussians yet
but you know you can ask these questions
in all of your favorite generative
models and these are beautiful
important very very very hard questions
yeah sorry just to add one thing to that
a list of open questions
the running time that we get is also
like d to the k to the k
and it's a great question to understand
whether you can improve it
great thanks um
okay so if if there are no further
questions
then uh let's all thank conker one more
time for this uh fabulous
second installment in his series and uh
we'll go to the coffee break in the
gather town
thanks